good morning Hank it's Tuesday greetings
from beautiful and somewhat windy
Chamberland South Dakota so link earlier
today I signed what I believed to be
every copy of turtles all the way down
currently available for sale or
borrowing in Sioux Falls South Dakota
and I met a lot of wonderful librarians
and booksellers and confused target
shoppers and I also filmed the whole
thing and it would have made a great
video but then I destroyed my memory
card what happened and I desperately
wish I were making this up is that I was
eating pretzel chips by the handful
because of course I was while fiddling
with my memory card and somehow my hands
got confused about what was what I mean
to be fair a memory card and a pretzel
chip have almost the exact same
thickness and overall weight but really
that's not a great excuse so yeah what
happened is that I put the memory card
into my mouth and then I chewed it the
weird part well actually I guess it's
all weird parts but the weirdest part is
that when I bit down on the memory card
my first thought was huh that pretzel
chip is very crunchy and so my natural
reaction was to attempt to chew it again
now it does not appear to be damaged
there's a couple very small tooth marks
but it's toast I'm gonna let this
frustration go in a minute but just as a
parting remark I would like to note that
it says right here on the memory card
that it is an Extreme Pro memory card
and look obviously I shouldn't have
chewed on my memory card but I would
argue that any non-food item that can be
destroyed by human chewing should not
describe itself as Extreme Pro all right
let's go on a tour bus bus tour hey
that's a palindrome nope no it is
definitely not so the first thing you
see when you come inside
is the drivers seat that's where Brock
lives once you walk onto the bus you
come to the first seating area which I
like to think of as the office it's sort
of the quiet part of the bus where
everybody's always on their computer
answering emails etc but the great thing
about the office is that it's also sort
of the dining room due to its proximity
to the kitchen by the way there are the
offending pretzel chips we really have
everything you need in a kitchen a
microwave a sink and a banana holder
past that you get to the bathroom we
have a very nicely appointed if somewhat
small bathroom but there's one very
important rule about the bus bathroom
which is no pooping and the bus bathroom
not because of like moral concerns but
you get that the tubes are too small
then you come to our refrigerator which
is mostly diet soda
Lucroy there's some beer there's some
baby carrots down there that nobody's
ever eaten and then past the bathroom we
have the
rooms eight beautiful bunks here's mine
I'm sorry I didn't make my bed for you
but here are two cute puppies I got at
Target headquarters thanks bunk is
directly beneath mine he didn't make his
bed either and then past the bedroom is
the second seating area which I like to
think of as like the rec room because it
contains my Nintendo switch so this is
kind of the hangout area because the
engines right back there it's a little
bit louder and there's more side-to-side
motion and when we first started on tour
everyone was really nauseated and nobody
wanted to sit back here but now we've
all got our bus legs the great thing
about the bus is that there's so much
storage like you know that bag which
contains 850 plastic Turtles in fact
there's plastic Turtles everywhere we've
got plastic Turtles in the shoe closet
we've got a cute little turtle moose in
the Sharpie drawer yes we have a Sharpie
drawer we've even got some holding
turtle fields in the microwave see he's
wearing his people hunting hat we've
even got Turtles with top hats in our
popcorn and applesauce drawer it really
is kind of a Turtles all the way down
situation okay Hank I'm gonna go hide
some signed plastic turtles here in
Chamberlain South Dakota we're leaving
them everywhere we stopped you can find
hints to their location on my Instagram
story and thanks again to everyone in
Sioux Falls who was so incredibly nice
to me sorry that I chewed on all of our
memories Hank I will see you on Friday
actually I'll see you like on Thursday
but you know what I mean